but yeah i i you know because i've
worked with obviously
young people who when i was starting the
ufc i had already gone to college
i was the oldest of the cast members and
i think that was also helpful for me too
because then i had some perspective you
know
right it was like i'd i'd graduate high
school i graduated college
i had struggled in new york for a minute
i'd come to l.a
um you know so i was in my early or
almost even mid-20s by the time the show
started a little old to be playing high
school students or whatever
isn't that the story of tv look at
smallville yeah i mean good lord welling
is playing a high school freshman and uh
jensen's the football coach who's got a
relationship with uh kristen krug's
character
lana lang and it's just like these guys
are grown men really and beverly hills
that's just kind of the way it is
totally and i mean it does bear
some i think it's worth noting you know
because i think
i do remember having that experience to
play like this is pretty weird that
we're
making them and it really was the men or
the boys whatever you want to call to
call us were were considerably older
than the girls like
adam and i adam brody and i were in our
early 20s i think were a year apart
and misha and rachel were younger
and it was like this is a weird thing
that we're like perpetuating
some weird stereotype of like what
masculinity is supposed to look like and
what
um femininity is supposed to look like
it's very strange i mean how much
younger were they
than you and adam i don't really
remember i mean i remember miesha being
very young like 17 or 18 years old
uh rachel i don't remember i want to say
she's like
maybe four years younger than me or
something maybe she was 20.
i was the only i was the only cast
member who had been to college
i think adam had done a semester or
something it was like i asked her this
i don't want to do this i want move to
to la and become an actor and he'd
already done like a series and
he he had the most i think he hit well
misha had credits
and he had the second most credits and
but i was the only one who'd actually
like
gone to college got a degree and not
that that
not that la could have cared at all
about that you know no one cares about
it for your growth though for your
growth that was important
perspective that i had perspective of of
you know
this is cool this is weird it's weird
that we're on a television show that you
know
that you happen to get on a television
show that happened to take off and is
pushing you out there uh the marketing
campaign has taken over and is pushing
you out a certain way that's a weird
experience it was helpful for me to have
some perspective to say ah
this is strange it's okay to feel
strange it's okay to like notice that
because i think otherwise you can get
caught up in it and go yeah
it can be some weird you know
never-ending quest for
validation or something that like you
know because
inevitably however hot you're burning at
the moment you're never going to stay
that hot
right oh yeah you know what i mean the
show lasts for i think that one last
small blessing forever it was he lasted
four years you know it's like
it was hot and and and you have to be
able to ride that out
you know you have to be able to like
make sense of your life
when when the lights are not on
you